life is directed by daniel espinosa and
stars the humongous cast of very
talented people and to sum up the plot
I'm going to tell you what I knew going
in because I just watched the teaser I
knew nothing else I stayed away from all
info so I knew that the movie was about
some astronauts who discover life on
Mars and it's not a comedy so it's
probably not going to be like a cakewalk
shit happens that's all I'm going to say
if a film involves characters who are
isolated in space and something bad is
happening I have a serious soft spot for
that one of my least favorite directors
of all time is Paul WS Anderson and I
can still tolerate and actually own the
blu-ray of event horizon because that
film is heavily inspired by alien which
is one of my favorites of all time and
obviously this movie takes a lot of
inspiration from alien as well but at
the same time there's a different
approach to the formula here where alien
is more of a science fiction horror film
this is almost a nonfiction horror film
this is more of a realistic look at what
would happen if we found a biological
life-form and things did not go as
planned it's not so much like a giant
spaceship filled with eggs and there's a
colony of you know it's nothing like
that it's just it's kind of more
realistic and it's a lot more grounded
than I expected it to be
which is something I really liked about
life and overall I had a blast watching
it this was a very suspenseful film
considerably better than Daniel
Espinoza's last film safe house which in
itself wasn't awful but this is
definitely a step up in regards to CG
this movie's gorgeous all the stuff in
space the way earth looks the space
station itself the entity that
eventually develops it all looks really
fucking good whenever you have a movie
that's very reliant on CG to accomplish
certain things it can suck you out of
the film if it's not convincing enough
and in this film they really nailed it
this is a gorgeous looking movie all the
actors also really excellent in this
movie Rebecca Ferguson Jake Gyllenhaal
Ryan Reynolds my favorite Japanese actor
of all time Hiroyuki Sanada is in this
movie and as always he's fantastic the
entire cast is phenomenal in this movie
one of the standouts is definitely
Rebecca Ferguson I was a little
disappointed in Jake Gyllenhaal's
character
not so much his performance I found that
his character was one of the weaker
aspects of the movie there wasn't that
much to him he has a hatred sorta for
people on earth and he just really likes
being in space
he doesn't really feel that he actually
wants to go back to earth he's about to
set a record for consecutive days spent
in space and so his character doesn't
have much to him besides the fact that
he's very antisocial and I was
disappointed in that because he's
usually the guy I zero in on in movies
as the best part of the movie he's in
but again his performance wasn't the
problem his character was just
underdeveloped there's another actor in
the film whose name I'm not going to
butcher until he eventually becomes more
famous and suddenly we all hear his name
a lot like my Hershel ollie now I can
say that because we've all heard it so
many times the actor in this film who
portrays the main scientist who operates
on this creature is really really great
and he has a disability in the film that
the writers found a very clever way to
utilize as an aspect to up the horror
that I genuinely did not expect this
movie had me on edge throughout the
majority in fact it is very suspenseful
as I said the CG and the acting is very
top-notch you really get the sense of
isolation that the filmmaker was going
for the opening sequence is this very
long take that's of course melded
together with CGI and various cuts but
it looks gorgeous it really looks
beautiful and I was really surprised by
life and a lot of that has to do with
the fact that I went in knowing nothing
about it I love doing that nowadays I'm
actually I'm not even watching anymore
trailers for alien covenant
I saw the one and I'm done I don't want
to know anything I want to go into
movies knowing as less as possible it
makes the experience better in the case
of life after seeing it a friend of mine
was like did you hear about that rumor
about what this movie was actually about
and I was like no and he told me I'll
talk to you guys about that after I gave
my grade because it's not really a
spoiler but it could affect your
expectations going in and I wouldn't
want to do that to you unless you were
aware of what I was about to talk about
it's tough to watch this movie and not
be reminded of other movies that are
better pretty much any movie in space
where characters are dealing with
something terrifying you're going to
think of alien even the movie sunshine
by Danny Boyle has shades of alien in
there we've all seen movies about people
having some sort of horrible thing
happened to them in space I enjoy those
movies quite a bit if they're well made
and life is definitely one of the better
ones I'm going to give it a B+ so again
this isn't a spoiler but it might affect
your expectations going in there was a
rumor going around that this movie was
an unofficial set up for venom it's not
it's really not and I just find it
hilarious that the one movie coming out
right now that's like a big giant movie
that's not a sequel it's not a reboot
it's not a spinoff it's not a prequel
it's nothing it's just a movie we still
had to turn it into an unofficial comic
book prequel before it even came out
yeah yeah that's fine Matt hilarious so
guys thank you so much as always for
watching I've been working on a rogue
one analysis since December and I can
finally release it this weekend because
the footage is coming out on digital so
I'll be able to complete the movie and
cut in some of the various shots I need
to do so I look forward to sharing that
with you guys as always if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
manoj
[Music]
Oh